"Stop the car!
Let me out!"
That's definitely me when I see a good sushi
place on the side of the road.
Welcome back to Things You Missed.
Today we're looking at the trailer for the
zombie film Cargo.
It's based off a 2013 short film of the same
name and the two directors of the short are
back to handle the feature.
I love to see that, so let's check out some
things you missed.
If you haven't seen the short, it's pretty
simple.
Dad wakes up in a car crash, mom is a zombie,
daughter is perfectly fine.
The Dad realizes he's been bit and devises
a contraption to keep his a daughter safe
until someone can find them.
Obviously you can't make a full feature off
of that, so I'll be taking about what was
added and what was changed as well.
Based on these opening shots, it seems that
the couple is living on a house boat, which
when it comes to zombie apocalypses, is a
good idea for safety, but isn't really sustainable
because you will run out of food and have
to go back on land to get more.
I'm guessing that's what happens here, because
a satellite dish wouldn't work on a boat,
so they must be on land when something gets
on to their boat.
My guess is whatever happened to these guys
happens to the Mom.
Something gets on the boat and gets her infected.
They must decide to take to the land to go
find help before her 48 hours are up, and
that sets the stage for where the original
short film begins with the car crash.
But before we go on from there, there's one
other thing you might have looked past, which
is all of these soldiers with their heads
buried in the ground.
That tells me a couple things.
First, that we're a little bit further into
this apocalypse, because the army had already
fought and presumably lost.
The short seems to take place possibly right
at the start of the apocalypse, given that
he put his daughter in the backpack for some
humans to find them, it's gotta be mostly
humans still at this point.
Second thing that this shot tells me is that
the only dead people we see in the trailer
who aren't walking around as zombies, have
their heads buried like this.
So maybe this is some kind of trap set by
humans.
Like maybe there's some yummy meat down there
and the zombies get stuck like that until
someone comes along and kills them off.
I know if someone put some fancy tuna in a
hole, I would be climbing down in there to
get it.
Let me know your thoughts on the buried heads
in the comments though.
Next I want to look at the zombies themselves.
We see that their eyes get glazed over and
they get this yellow-green mold over their
skin.
If I had to guess, I'd say that points to
this being a viral infection.
This is the point where the Dad realizes he's
going to be infected too, and has to find
someone to care for Rosie, so he sets off
on foot and comes across a village that seems
to have electricity thanks to these solar
powered lights.
There's a quick shot here of this balloon.
In the short, he ties a balloon to himself
to increase his visibility and entertain the
baby, so this could be a little reference
to that.
I think the tribal kid he meets, is an Aboriginal
Australian native.
So this picture of the rival from Pokemon
Silver, a Rick and Morty character named Willie
and Jeffrey Tamboor might actually just be
the family -- with the kid, the dad and this
might be the Shaman of their village who could
be significant if he possesses some kind of
healing remedy.
This kid is not present in the short film
and looks to be a major part of this feature.
My guess is that this kid is introduced into
the plot as kind of a gauge for the main guy's
character development.
When they first meet, the kid's father has
already turned, and the main character's advice
is to let go.
"That wasn't your dad anymore."
But I think that he's the one who is going
to learn how hard it is to let go of a loved
one, even if it's for the best, and that this
will be his main obstacle in the movie.
The film's title, Cargo, has not changed from
the short film, but I do think it takes on
a 2nd meaning here.
Originally, the baby Rosie is the cargo.
He's trying to transport her to safety.
And that's still true.
But I also noticed that the survivor camp
they come across is filled with these cargo
storage units.
I'm guessing they sleep in these things for
pritection.
So not only is the baby the cargo, but everyone's
the cargo.
And my last thing you missed for this trailer
is something I'd like to open a discussion
about in the comments.
The Aboriginal kid's dad has this G symbol
on his clothing, and the sniper later on at
the survivor camp has the same symbol on his
hat.
So what do you think the meaning is behind
that?
Is there some kind of connection between these
characters?
If you are looking forward to seeing where
they take this movie, give this video a like.
I think the next Things You Missed I'm gonna
do is A Quiet Place.
So make sure you subscribe and ring the deathbell
for notifications so you don't miss that and
I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.